i remember if there was ever a time
where i liked a girl yeah and another
dude that liked her oh i wouldn't like
that girl
really yeah i had me to be like all
right because some some people will go
for 30 years
[Music]
chance the rapper was like it was like
trendy on twitter he spent like thirty
thousand dollars on post mates
in the last year and it was like who did
chance the rapper yeah i was like he
probably makes [ __ ]
500 times as much money and i probably
spent 10 grand
to us like that's probably that ain't
[ __ ] that ain't [ __ ] oh during the
pandemic i wonder how much i spent on
postmates oh
yeah like you're like the height of [ __ ]
on average that breaks down to 2500
a month i can see him doing that if he
lives a very busy life and he just needs
food like while he's on the go i cannot
i could i could absolutely see that this
was since 2014.
oh he's fine yeah
oh that's nothing i bet i have spent
that
i'm not kidding
i think a lot of people have spent yeah
i think a lot of people spend that yeah
that makes me nervous though yeah i
don't want to look back on my history to
see because i kind of want to know how
much money i've spent over the years on
postmates alone because that doesn't
then include doordash or ubereats or all
the other [ __ ] [ __ ] that i've used
you can get one of those like budgeting
apps like mint
yeah i think it can like it'll like give
you like i don't know i don't want to
see the number i like i have it
downloaded but i don't really
i have a i have a pretty detailed
yeah monthly budget spreadsheet that i
have but then like
but mint's really good though yeah
uh-huh well when you use it yeah i think
i think it can i think it can be uh my
black people recommend it i i've had it
since like 2008 yeah yeah yeah it's been
around for a minute
i should use it
even though i don't buy i mean i buy a
lot of t-shirts yeah
but do you ever get nervous about
overspending
or are you someone who just stays in
your budget
i'm the same way i feel like i have
periods where i spend damn near nothing
except for like the bare minimum of what
i need and then there are months where i
spend way too much yeah
but not like
i say we keep this on the podcast i like
this discussion yeah should we just
start with that
the last expensive thing i like
tell them no hurricane uh probably
probably something with guitars yeah
yeah oh speaking of guitars
i started collecting things now too i am
now collecting uh handbags
okay i've i've officially gone into that
realm of chanel and all that yeah
because i found out that um you can
resell them for a crazy amount of money
you know because she looks like shoes
yeah it's like it's like shoes except
for i think that you don't
you can actually wear the bags and still
make money without kind of like damaging
it because as long as you have a bag in
good condition no one really cares if
you wore it whereas if you have shoes
and you wear it and then you try to
resell it the value really isn't the
same yeah unless you have something
crazy like uh i don't know the red
yeezys or something yeah or you're not
wearing them at all like you have them
for dead stock but with bags i guess
since there was such a limited supply
during the pandemic stores like chanel
have made it a policy where you could
buy only one bag a month so people who
are used to buying chanel who are used
to like throwing money at this
like expensive bag now want it more and
the price has increased but they could
resell it for an extra grand or two like
you can buy a bag for five thousand
dollars in store and sell it on the
street for six six thousand dollars easy
that same day and then you're you're
you're uh hedging against inflation
goods money dollars not worth anything
get rid of your cash get banks
what are you collecting the new
i buy a lot of equipment
and and they're like big purchases so
like and it's but the resale value on
that is also good it's true those those
hold up um if you take care of it which
i'm not good with my stuff i'm so like
i don't know i just move so fast i break
stuff and i lose stuff and i spill on it
but i'm like i'm just like
can't slow down more
more
coal
but doesn't [ __ ] slow down at all but
yeah so that's where my my money goes as
i've made more money like i'm uh i'm a
zero-sum game regardless of how much i'm
making i i was living in los angeles on
twenty-five thousand dollars and
perfectly happy but yeah now i also have
the same amount of money saved up which
yeah if you're if you if you don't have
any kids or anything like or much
responsibilities you can survive on 25
grand out here yeah hardcore had a
living room 400 bucks a
did you month
see a tick tock that's angering people
where a woman says that she like and as
an adult she made kind of a broad term
saying as an adult uh making ten
thousand a month isn't
a lot of money it's just enough to
survive and so many people were so angry
at her for saying that because ten
thousand dollars is a lot but i think
once you factor it i think regardless of
where you live assuming she lives in a
expensive city like let's say la okay 10
000 is still a lot of money i i just
don't understand what she was talking
about 10 000 a month is a lot yeah
like even if you set side of money for
your taxes yes like for your rent your
overhead cost of living month to month
10 000 is a [ __ ] lot yeah she's
saying like she's like after everything
she ends up with yeah but she was also
kind of coming at it from the
perspective of like i'm an adult i'm a
woman who likes nice things so ten
thousand isn't a lot for me
so that's like the way to maintain the
level of living that i
want for myself ten thousand isn't a lot
so a lot of people got angry because
saying the broad statement of ten
thousand dollars isn't a lot of money to
live off of in a month people are like
that's [ __ ] but when you actually
kind of listen to what she's saying
she's saying from my lifestyle for her
life
okay i guess you know i reacted off
emotion i reacted often i'm with you i
got a little hype i got a little hype
well if you want that lifestyle you
better be prettier willing to work yeah
woman yeah like
i don't know you can't like
have this expectation of this lifestyle
but then have no way of
bringing that in yeah i don't think i
have any issue with someone saying stuff
like that as long as they're the ones
maintaining their own lifestyle but if
you kind of throw that around as like a
broad
statement and you're not the one
bringing that lifestyle to you i feel
like that's [ __ ] oh one hundred
percent if someone else is like what are
you doing for the
man
you don't know anything about her uh no
it's just that that one video i saw hey
any troubles hit us up we just we just
posted last night so it's pretty quick
turnaround we're great
we're recording this on monday which we
don't usually yeah yeah we normally
don't record on mondays chappelle and i
are going out of town yeah yeah shout
out to the threfels though
you troubles better hit us up and stop
playing i'm also so curious because last
week we were talking about the uh two
males one female throttle i'm curious
about the two males one male throbble
like two two two males one female like
how does that i don't know that does
that work the same way like the man is
bi she did yeah she she's told the story
a lot on podcast she lived with two men
before bobby lee and they were all
dating oh wow they were all dating yeah
so the dudes were [ __ ] with
mm-hmm there's there's a clip of it were
they i don't want to watch each other or
like always with her uh
[Music]
that's a good question actually i think
because if it's two straight men like
men and one straight woman i feel like
that's like a little um
like uh
it it doesn't even itself out but both
men were bi
and she was into men i feel like that's
more equal playing field whereas like in
your situation it was two women who were
bi and then the man who was straight
yeah so like the women can hook up with
each other as well yeah whereas if it's
two straight men like they're not
hooking up yeah i wonder how often you
see it that way yeah that's right but
also like i feel like that happens a lot
dudes have such massive egos that i
don't know if they could drop the ego
and be like we're both being with this
girl yeah you know what i mean yes
absolutely i don't know how often that
hap that happens where it's actually
comfortable and it's actually a happy
situation whereas maybe there's issues
behind the scene right that's that's
what i yeah the reason why i think about
it because i mean i remember if there
was ever a time where i liked a girl
yeah and another dude that liked her oh
i wouldn't like that girl anymore really
yeah i had me to be like all right cause
some some people will go for 30 years
[Laughter]
that kept happening
it happened quite often unless you have
like a really unique taste i love that
you just let up instead of being like
you know what i'ma compete because i
don't want to [ __ ] compete i don't
it's a
i'm not going to fight for your love
yeah i just don't want to [ __ ]
well what if she liked you more
then that's fine and that's fine that's
fine are you saying she didn't like you
is that situation and that's fair too
you know these are all fair points
if she liked me but it but i think it
was just like okay let me take that back
i think if i if i was attracted to a
girl and another dude was as well yeah
then i would kind of just fall back i
was like all right but i ain't doing
this
i'm not gonna i'm not getting no [ __ ]
no [ __ ]
rumble over
no rumble in the bronx for her [ __ ] no
i could do it by the way great movie by
the way homegirl in that movie hot as
[ __ ] i actually never admitted to this
i've never watched rumble on the bronx i
just pretend like i did because everyone
would talk
about all of it
what are we doing oh [ __ ] it was cats
after dark sorry i did not introduce
this uh welcome back to another episode
of cats after dart we kind of were just
rolling so forgive us if we were just
rum
rumbling rambling
in the dark
rumbling in the dark i personally like
that that dynamic of like we kind of
cold open into it and then all of a
sudden oh no here's our intro yeah yo so
scroll down i think it's uh what do you
want to see her name oh you're looking
for the writer jackie chan
the girl he was fighting for in that
movie was beautiful
her talk to uh todd
it's the third one was it her nose the
third one are you sure watch go back
it's that one right there that one when
she was younger
typing young
yeah i guarantee you
you guarantee i guarantee you
yeah there she is
smoking wow
right
she's bad yeah she's still killing that
what's that what's that new picture look
like i didn't really get to see it
show that new new that updated
you get that man
well she looks like a lady yeah
yeah if that's her right now that she
looks really good she's gotta be like 50
right that movie 30 years ago yeah that
movie came out in the 90s
95 i want to say that movie came out it
came out when i was born
she's 49 40.
she's good for 49. yeah she's just great
shout out to friends
that was like me yelling at out the
speed of an ostrich i was one of them
hello shout out to frank kois
yup francois francois oh
frank baby
i know that movie [ __ ] great i love
that movie that used to be my sister's
go-to movie when it was still on netflix
for her to go to sleep like the uh
background oh yeah yeah that's good
background noise uh movie
what do you listen to on background do
you do you do that i do that all the
time i have [ __ ] just playing and i'm
not really paying attention
uh just like in general
oh background good background stuff for
me i think i have anything
but i tell you what i do have i have
specific movies for flights for flights
yes what type of movies do you like
watching on flights it's all it's a lot
of it's my favorite movies oh it's just
like saving space heavy hitters over and
over yep got it saving silverman
don't know i guess
i don't know i love savings oh you know
amanda amanda p was just trending
yesterday on twitter because people were
people were like respond to this picture
and it was of amanda p if you think
she's extremely famous and like
everybody's like sailor silva you're
saving so
seriously yeah yeah save yourself that
movie jack black was amazing at it he
was so cool so good i love this so is
arlene
he's the coach
yeah he's a coach from uh fullmetal
jacket full metal jacket rest in peace
so i totally forgot oh yeah that one
yeah blue streak with martin lawrence
mm-hmm that's one
uh tombstone mm-hmm yep four brothers oh
four brothers a good one both equalizers
both i both i taken
and then uh that's a lot of action
movies
love straight out of compton so much yes
i was obsessed with that movie and i had
the biggest crush on o'shea jackson jr
because of that i didn't think he was
going to be a good actor he was great
he played his dad he played his dad i
don't know his cube ice cube
ice cube son
he said who did he play
i was in love with him when that movie
came out like absolutely obsessed with
him
one of my favorite biopics
i've said that wrong
i know i was like bye
bye bye that's his kid yeah yeah oh wow
right so similar man how hard i need to
watch that movie because like we've said
we're the same person uh
but
and every other movie you said on that
list like i [ __ ] so those are movies
you could do for flights yes well see i
actually have a tough tough five for a
flight
i have a different theory on flights if
you're flying from
los angeles to [ __ ] west palm beach
florida
i feel like direct flight
were you watching
see when i really mean i knew it what i
do on flights because i'm like this is
the one time i don't have like any
distractions whatever i'll watch a movie
i've never seen
uh oh okay and i'm like i'm gonna sit
here and watch this and like something
that like recently i watched eternal
sunshine the spotless mind which i knew
everybody loves that movie uh i've never
watched it huh what was it called
eternal sunshine the spotless mind jim
carrey
it's awesome uh that girl winslow what
kate winslet winslet yeah christian
dunce mark ruffalo
you should watch out your next flight
but you won't you'll be able to straight
up
or four brothers yeah
watch very stressful movies oh gosh i
know or b and john malkovich was another
one i watched recently had never seen it
uh knew it was revered
um
nobody likes the movies i've watched
recently on flights but this is my new
thing
this is my new thing that i do on
flights yeah so those are you like your
cues but all those movies are ones i
would i would like fall asleep i fall
asleep to or if i see him on tv i'll sit
down and watch the rest of him i [ __ ]
love him wait did i say tombstone yeah
yes okay i just want to make sure oh you
got it oh i'm sure i said you got it i
saw equalizer clips a bunch of clips on
youtube and i really want to watch them
but you only watch i think i watched the
first one the whole movie but i just
been pop it's like equalizer two clips
have been popping up like crazy on my
youtube so i'll just watch it and
they're so good the scenes are so good
it's because i throw off your door
including your algorithm probably
it's like the instagram thing what do
you do on flights
interesting you ask because i had a long
flight to
the great lakes and so there's a
different movie so i actually i didn't
want to watch it
because i i'm not i don't like will
smith right now
but king richard was on so i was like
[ __ ] i gotta watch it i heard it was
good that's a great movie yeah it's a
great [ __ ] movie he overdoes the the
dad's like speech though right i mean
like he over does it a little bit but
yeah but it was really really good i saw
i came in like 20 minutes late to the
movie because they were watching at home
i had no idea what was going on it was
so good that it just sucked me and they
got like invested in this emotional are
they giving that movie backlash now no
they better not yeah they better let
that movie be by the movie as it
separates the man from yeah
yes brad pitt was on it and he played a
musician
and he had growing pains growing pains
so brad pitt was on brad pitt
but he played like this famous musician
that ben was like upstairs
[Laughter]
so ben loved him right you see him right
the picture with him in the guitar and
ben
yeah see he was like we loved him and he
had this song about like loving his
girlfriend and then ben went to the
concert and went to the green room and
he isn't bad character was cheating on
the girl with another girl making out
he's like how could you do that you made
this song about you know so then i think
his dad told him like don't worry about
that that's the music is the music and
he is he like you could still love the
music that's a reminder
all
right
man that one dude said he they claimed
to predict his death oh yeah sorry that
was aggressive on him
uh the young kid clairvoyant yeah
the guy he said he uh
did he say you predicted his death wait
who are we talking about the clairvoyant
that's talking about alan thicke he was
doing the oh tyler the the twink yes
yeah yeah he had his own show on e his
name was tyler something oh
kardashian for a while
that's crazy because i have a whole
podcast about him and i didn't cover
that uh you guys can check out the
podcast it's called thick boy
it is what it's just a joke
[Laughter]
just a firefighter
that guy i don't know if he said he i
don't know if he claimed he predicted i
think he said something about a health
issue he says about a health issue and
that was the way he had a heart attack
yeah yeah three uh what they say
did he want i don't know if he
necessarily warned him though
no he was telling him
he has he thinks there's some issues but
there was take care but i guess there
was a history
like it was a hereditary thing in his
family yeah i mean there you go because
i looked it up
he said something be careful there's a
clip on it meatball on youtube
just um go to the at nevermind yeah go
to tyler
what's this guy named tyler henry
uh scroll meatball you got this no no no
i know i'm just i'm just that's the
video
oh you guys want to watch a video it's a
real quick one it's like really really
quick
when he was just 10 years old tyler
go to youtube meatball
you got this i believe in you
my new goal is to just say nice things
about meatball i don't think it's gonna
last yeah i was just about to say let's
see how long do you think it is
it's like a limited sandwich you say
something nice and then you insult him
and then you say something nice so then
and then my chappello meter is going to
go off
every time he says something crazy
startling
alan thicke as he sat down with a
hollywood medium listen to this warning
about his heart when it comes to like a
family and a gene perspective it's
possible that within your family there
might be multiple men who end up at a
later age dealing with blood pressure
issues but also deal with either a heart
murmur or heart arrhythmia three months
after the taping of
that's it
that's the warning that's so broad
though you could say that to anybody
the show no
especially if you knew the family
history yeah oh you're saying you're
getting old oh that means you could die
soon like that's how broad it is
yeah we talk about blood pressure yeah i
mean i don't know i don't believe in
himself he was christian one day i could
see
possibly just cardiac arrest
now let's get should we do predictions
now let's get nick assertive nick can be
a certified clanfordian now there we go
this dude this dude's like big time with
this [ __ ] like he goes on the road yeah
he does like tours oh yeah i think it
looks insane because a lot of people who
claim to have like this clairvoyant or
like psychic abilities some of them have
such crazy clientele
where just like people with unlimited
amounts of money going to them throwing
money at them like oh what's going to
happen in my future should i take this
role in this role hold on i guess
i just completely agree with your
philosophy that like these these people
who
as long as you have like the confidence
and the the ability
and the courage to stick with this even
if you think it's a lie yeah there's
gonna be you can find a dumb ignorant
audience who will continue to pay you
and i mean like
like that guy uh we had on king and the
sting uh he's a he was a comic in l.a
i love thomas yeah he's he seems super
fun very friendly that [ __ ]
ain't psychic you can send him
you can send him this clip
he probably already knows you're talking
[ __ ]
he just walks in he just walks in the
back door so i heard you were talking
[ __ ] yeah
he did immediately sense my uh skeptical
energy when we did have a we just zoomed
him in
he was like i can't tell nick back there
doesn't believe i made him a little bit
more flamboyant i was gonna say i feel
like every uh cause that guy was
flamboyant and then there's this guy
back home i know who claims to be a clan
boy completely [ __ ] talked exactly
the way nick just did
so maybe that's maybe that's a clear
voice people are just paying these
[ __ ] no i've heard a lot of
stories of rich people with a lot of
money who
almost feel like they want to have some
sort of control over their future by
having someone tell them what to do
that's my perspective on it yeah i don't
know whether these people have the
ability or not but there is a like a
group of people who want to have such
control
over a feeling of control over their
future that they'll go to someone and
say hey what should i do this or this
what are the outcomes going to be and
it's like a form of like i want to be
able to control what happens to me
yeah like yeah yeah
i also want someone to tell me good
things about it also i also heard yeah
it's kind of weird you can learn that
you can learn how to do this [ __ ] mm-hmm
like you like there's certain questions
you can ask which is okay oh that's what
you mean someone explained it to me like
this the way the way they can do it okay
put it this way it's like uh if you're
on stage you're oh i guess i'm the only
stand-up comic game well anyways if
you're on stage you're dealing with a
heckler you know you do to heckler
you ask them a question
and then they say something
which
you can find exactly like they tell you
just off of something little
a heckler can give you everything you
know about them with with just
i don't know saying something
completely [ __ ] dumb in this in the
sense of stand-up comedy so you're able
to read people now you're able to read
them immediately based off of what they
say because that's what you do
when you deal with a heckler you read
them and you just ask them a simple
question like it can be like easy as
like oh what do you do
and then they and then they can say what
they do and then based off of their work
they just let you know everything about
them mm-hmm she's like chappelle i'm
kind of i'm sensing like some pain in
your life have you have a family member
fall ill or pass away recently or in the
last 12 years
is it is there anybody coming to mind
anybody coming here oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
who was that who was that yes yes yeah
who was that yeah who
who who my brother yeah that's why i was
sensing brother o'sun's brother i'm also
sensing like a j
or an m or an s or a t name
maybe you know
his last name was james
[Laughter]
you guys were either close or there was
a difference
yeah yeah yeah we did have a real close
yeah yes yes we had a riff before um
that's so [ __ ] crazy because that's
exactly telling me he wants you to
uh
be super successful for him and that's
all he needs
and now you feel better and now you will
pay me the next now chapel's crying
easy
i think you do it meatball no i'm just
no i can't do it nick was very
convincing i'm just saying
i would like to try to commit to it like
a [ __ ] oh that'd be hilarious all of a
sudden nick just [ __ ] runs with this
[ __ ] and starts making bank
come see nick davis live see if you're
smart about it i feel like you need to
reach a global audience and just start a
patreon for stuff like that i wonder how
much that kid [ __ ] makes tyler henry
he must be super you can never trust
those things well okay we'd probably
give us a gauge or if you go to his
website i'm sure you can figure out if
he's on tour like we are oh yeah how
much does this ticket
figure out that yeah we could do with
that hey i guess there's
money i do that kind of math all the
time that's that's fun math what kind
what this performer what venue they're
doing what are ticket sales what is it
770 dollars well that's
uh december 21st uh 20 december 2012 it
seems like this is a this is an old tour
okay
but then
paramount theater denver colorado this
looks april 24th 2022 125 lowest prices
70 dollars what is it what what's the
first date in colorado
april 24th damn it i'm there 20 the 20th
to the 20th oh gosh if nick could have
[ __ ] gone to that that would report
it back to us
so it would have been another corey
feldman thing yeah
i know yeah
it would have been hilarious holy [ __ ]
why is this one so much money
um i don't know so click it
i wonder if it's like a home show and he
has a very large audience there oh it's
only oh nevermind it's a theater
and so what i wonder what he does at his
live show does he just pick out guests
or he has guests that he brings with
them
i don't know i'm sure there's a section
of it at the very top he kind of gives
an introduction to him and his story
he brings somebody yeah he brings
somebody off he does it live see i was
told that people like when people go to
the show like i know someone who went to
one and
they she knew that she was gonna talk to
the guy on the show so i thought that
maybe they all knew like look that's
what i mean
people go on the show and they already
know that they're gonna talk to the
client yeah it's planned out so what's
stopping that guy from doing that
research he knows he was gonna have on
know all the family issues so obviously
they're gonna do research and make it
look like he's a [ __ ] clairvoyant but
but look at it this way the way uh cause
nick okay so say
okay so you don't have a sister right no
so nick you do it
[Laughter]
done
and that's how it's done
literally say you don't have a sister
right or you don't have a sister i don't
have like oh i'm sisting a sister
right yeah then you're like oh i don't
have a sister but i have someone that's
like my sister yes you know what i mean
yeah i watched a lot of sister sister
yeah yes
but you'll say this thing that's what
i'm saying it's like what a like what
you do to a heckler you know what do you
do for work i think they just know how
to steer the conversation and make it
look like yeah you're in control yeah
yeah exactly you're you're so engaged
with them you're listening to everything
they say so you're like
oh well i don't have a sister but i have
this person that's like my sister that i
grew up with that's basically a close
friend of mine you know whatever blah
blah blah because there's an assumption
from the audience that you are
real so if you say something about
sister there's gotta be it's i'm the
ones wrong if i can't think of anything
that
yeah you're automatically connecting the
dots for him wait wait say that i'm
saying what you're saying like the
person who you say something about the
sister to
they feel like they're wrong if they
can't think of what you're talking about
so they'll search for any
grain of truth to be like yes he's right
i think the cat's after dark crew should
go to one of these shows
and see what happens two thousand
dollars that
my family does a lot of these in vietnam
i remember doing the uh king the sting i
sent in a photo of me doing one with a
guy who was like
like a man baby he was like wearing just
his underwear and he speaks in tongues
he had like a woman translate for him
yeah we talked about possibly trying to
get that can we do the man baby zoom him
in i don't think so i think he goes like
they do village to village right they do
it for free but they also take donations
so it's a little like oh yeah and
apparently he speaks in tongues and
there's a woman with him who
follows him everywhere he goes because
she's the only one who can understand
what he's saying
he's like
that guy's in front of the families he's
like help me this woman has kidnapped me
and she's like yeah he says
he says more donations would help his
vision
do you think there's actual real type of
sort of clairvoyance though do you think
they're all [ __ ] i don't know
i think maybe
maybe like very very like
limited i don't know yeah i feel like if
there is it's rarer than we do because
i mean this man's been able to make a
career off of but he's not the only one
that's done that before there's no
island medium yeah long item it was a
lady with the hair yeah with the hair
lady with the hair there's another one
before her too that's part of the guy
and he had a tv show oh yeah yeah i
think they got they got uh
called called out or something like that
what do you mean the guy by the tv show
matt fraser
what was that his name i don't know no
it was like jay or something famous male
clairvoyant
not
gay
we're talking about it so there's none
oh there was jim crossing over with
i think something happened with him
where he got caught and before him there
was a girl on maury povich she also got
caught she was apparently working with
fbi fbi to find bodies and she was able
to find one but then they called her out
on like making a bunch of like fake [ __ ]
yeah wait so she was able to find a body
because something she was saying like
she left like she led cops to a certain
thing oh
yeah don't get me wrong like there are
some situations where it is kind of like
the
simpsons have predicted a [ __ ] oh yes
that's why i'm like maybe it's possible
but definitely added more rare this guy
got called out i think he did but i
don't remember do you know christian
that a lot of times
the simpsons have called out a lot of
stuff because they've done so much stuff
but like a lot of times when something
happens in the news the simpsons will
draw it up like they do their artwork
and then they tweet it it goes viral and
they're like oh look the simpsons
predicted this really but they're just
like playing a prank on it there's a
number of those that have been pretty
close
some of them are like yeah they're kind
of crazy but at the same time i'm like
so how what would i look up that uh
simpsons did it hoax
or simpsons predicted at hoax
um but in it as he looks that up a
couple couple updates first we have uh
james beshara ceo of magic mine uh
zooming in in five minutes
uh
just uh learn a little bit more about
him and thank him for uh supporting the
show um also the one guy who had a sixth
grader uh who wants to like challenge
yes one one of us or all of us i don't
know it's gonna be like iron chef where
they get to choose who they want to
battle yeah it's
oh i i like that i love that it's uh
it's his daughter um uh maleen or uh
marley malin ackermann maleen ackermann
mali you know that sounds better he said
it's pronounced like the the actress
molina ackerman but i don't know her
name i don't know that either i'm going
to say moline um
it's his daughter moline
she's pretty bright straight a's all
pre-ap classes
uh so she's she's a formidable foe how
old does she say he's or sixth grade
she's in sixth grade she wants to be he
wants to put her up against this yeah
and i i will not
well
i think it should be up to her to choose
who she wants to go up but not pick me
up
because here's the thing i don't know
about your schools ap wasn't allowed in
the school system where i grew up until
you were in
high school so for her
ap
that's i think it's like a great school
version of the same thing so eventually
she'll transfer to [ __ ]
god okay meatball you don't want to go
yeah i mean you're probably same height
so you got to go against him so
those two things and also uh
subscribe to the audio on spotify and
apple podcast and follow at cats after
dark underscore on instagram
so john edward got caught yeah i don't
know i got caught but oh i brought that
up because um i talked about this
because your vietnamese thing reminded
me of it which i'm sure i talked about
on that cat's episode but so one of my
friends passed away from cancer
his mom hired one of those you know
whatever clairvoyance they're also
vietnamese vietnamese she said
straight up he's not going to make it to
his 39th birthday
he literally when he got cancer we were
with him he died the day after his 39th
birthday
so then i i when they told me that i'm
like like he was five today after yeah
literally like the day after so he he
fought so hard but then he just kind of
gave up after his 30th birthday and
like that that close why 39
and literally he died like the day after
yeah but the the timing of it the timing
of it yeah it was so trippy so that made
me think like [ __ ] just some people
actually really know [ __ ]
she they were wrong
yeah
i know you would say
that's what i was gonna say at the end
of the day
she was [ __ ] wrong
she's wrong because he made her wrong
but i mean she probably was right but he
just fought it like way harder than he
he's like [ __ ] her i'm going to last one
more day
before he was like no
how many months did they give him or
something like no it came back like he
was was going away for a while and we
thought we were you know take him back
home he could be fine but then it came
back really strong and then yeah it just
got difficult and she was like he won't
make it to his 39th birthday no she said
it when he was like what when he was
born oh she said yeah oh
that happens a lot too a lot of a lot of
vietnamese will bring their children to
these yeah
and they'll make predictions when
they're kids
it's cool to make like no no yeah i
don't i'd not rather maybe light up this
but she failed the class pretty much
even when you said uh like he was just
trying to prove her wrong that was like
one time i held off on making the joke
yeah because i was like oh that's but
then you did so game on
no but my mom used to do stuff like that
when we were kids too she did it for me
my sister and my younger brother all
when we were kids and they all had
predictions which is kind of insane
because when i was i remember the first
time she did it and she told me about it
i was in middle school and the sidekick
said she's gonna have she's going to
have a career in entertainment she's
going to be very successful just so just
let her do whatever it is she wants to
do don't force her to go to college for
something that she doesn't want to do
and then the moment i got fired in the
kid my mom's like i [ __ ] knew it the
psychics told me really it's true though
hey look at can you learn how to be a
clairvoyant this is a different guy no
no no i'm just but it's an interesting
quote that i'm no i'm just saying
because he's like how to be a
clairvoyant this is it tells you how you
got it
uh so go ahead and read it out for us
meatball me
[Laughter]
yeah uh the psychic business is built on
lies there's no supernatural power you
can't see the future edward says we're
in the gold age of the con
there are people coming out of the
woodwork that would love to separate you
from your money but people just want
someone to talk to that's the bottom
line and this is oh this is the chris
every guy no no no this is a different
guy who
former psychic hotline worker and author
of uh psychic blues mark edward said
he's blowing the whistle on his former
industry
it's a two billion dollar a year in this
house what about the [ __ ]
psychics that tell people to break up
with their [ __ ] peoples
okay like oh what's that that tv lady's
name is uh miss cleo miss cleo
whether she the og call me now for your
free reading
i don't know how good that was but
it's solid i remember miss clio
and they charged by the minute which is
the insane part because because yeah
they're not broke they make a lot of
money they absolutely even i like what
is the [ __ ]
like even even ones that aren't even
like famous for doing the [ __ ] yeah i
don't think like everyone makes money
but i think if you have a certain amount
of clientele you're making bank i think
if you can hook people in and get them
as a recurring customer you're making
big regardless especially if you go in
and like say you you did it and you tell
us about it we're like oh [ __ ] at least
one of us is gonna [ __ ] someone
desperate enough
you know the word of mouth keeps going
there there there there there so you
asked how to do it this is what he would
do it says what uh abc news asked this
guy what tricks of the trade would you
use he said you have to gauge the tone
of a person's voice if they're
aggressive or laid back in a hurry or
skeptical the first five or four words
are important then i ask for their name
and birthday and if they have a specific
question
a three at four dollars a minute they
want to answer quick
and
i'm on then i'm i answer as if i'm
answering the question about myself so
basically yeah so it's all bait
basically
kinda so they're trying to be relatable
in order to get information out of you
yes
it changes it it's oh nice you can bring
them in it's like the exact same thing
as a sex worker
like a phone sex operator basically like
you could do it for either profession
yeah not that i've ever called i really
haven't that seems that's super cool
think about the type of people that do
call it
they used to be on infomercials all the
time the moment 9 pm passes all those
involved
who needs someone to talk to that bad in
a sexual way they're like 18 and over
only yeah right there's stupid-ass
commercials local singles
meanwhile you don't know what the
[ __ ] person looks like would you just
call
and usually they say they usually
they're really big really big
yeah
have you seen the mad tv sketch of it
it's basically
uh no i don't think brian was in that
one it's basically where the mom turned
out to be the sex worker and the uh kid
was like praying calling them hi
can you hear us
in progress can you hear us
nice
there he is
am yes any time of the day we take our
magic wand look at us
oh that's so awesome we call this the
magic mine slap yeah the magic while i
slept
yeah that's right
it's like a dip can yeah
yeah i just got really excited to show
how well i can uh pack a tin
and i threw it across the room but i can
do it pretty well oh yeah yeah
look at that oh yeah that actually oh
yeah but uh take your magic mine oh we
are of course talking to james vasheira
ceo of magic mine ashwagandha
there we go
that's right that's right
some people call it ashwaganga i'm not
going to tell you why i think i know why
but it might help down there oh oh
is this an aphrodisiac that's one thing
for pat it is
not an aphrodisiac but it does help with
uh performance sex drive
wait really
look at me balls all excited
i just couldn't tell if i was a joke or
not
we need the opposite of that for
football i think he's yeah people yeah
you got a lot of jobs
23. yeah 23 you got a live drive well
james uh
we wanted to have you on and thank you
for your support of uh magic mind and we
wanted to get uh your perspective on it
i mean i think we do a pretty good job
of selling it for you but uh tell us
when you started it
well i will say that you guys may be the
best
job of selling for an advertiser i've
ever heard and that's
and i i don't i don't even know where it
comes from maybe it's just a genuine
maybe it's honestly i can't tell if it's
if it is man they're so charitable and
generous or if it is the savvy of just
you guys have know that you've been in
the game long enough your vets to where
you're like hey if we if we try to just
like i don't know
run through advertisers then then no one
wins but whatever the reason uh
thank you thank you thank you for uh all
of the promo you all have done for our
little company yeah i would say the
number one reason is the efficacy of the
product yep
and
and my need to be focused number two
i it's content i mean this is this is
ten minutes of a show we got yeah
we got airspace we got airspace to fill
so either way it works
it's changed your pal's life changed my
life i no longer freak out on it i'm
good
dude yeah tell actually i mean i know
that y'all touched on in previous
episodes but yeah chappelle what's been
the the arc like of going from i know in
episode one you're like dude what the
hell is this they're pretty skeptical oh
they just said stop being a [ __ ]
so then i was like oh okay i got this
but it definitely helped you as like a
like an opening to take more caffeine
because you're drinking an ice cream now
he never drinks caffeine it was a
gateway drug
[Laughter]
yeah dude we're we're the rogue the
rogue uh we're kind of like the
guerrilla warfare for starbucks get more
people on caffeine yeah get them into uh
into that zone where they can drink
habit but i the i remember you saying
caffeine gave you jitters and it kind of
freaked you out so it's been oh yeah no
and when i really think about it that
day i think i was just freaking out
because i was like man i don't want i
don't want to get freaking all hyped or
anything like that
but literally
nothing of that it's refreshing well
well it's it has been nearly a decade of
research in the formula and um and it
started from when i was drinking six to
seven cups of coffee a day
and i just had no idea i remember
reading like a
a cnn money article talking about how
you can have up to five cups of coffee a
day and now when i look back i was like
why the hell was i getting my info from
cnn money and it must have been just
some bs kind of like big coffee uh
coffee growers association of america
kind of pushed uh research because i had
no idea it was doing some pretty pretty
big biological damage uh in my life
sending me an er with a heart condition
so it's it really is is it started for
the first seven years of me just
developing it for myself developing it
for myself and
and it really is this um
this concoction that gives you energy
but you don't feel amped on it
uh like most people are kind of afraid
of yeah when you give them an energy
drink yeah that's why yeah no it's the
best product i think i've taken ever
yeah
and and i threw that in there i threw
that in there we lost you for a second
james i threw that in there dog
no it's uh hey james where you going you
pissed him off you you he saw the wink
so he left
james i think he saw the i think he saw
the winky left he can see you you know
that's okay
yeah why'd you win directly
hey the wink was like hey it's good
oh wait y'all thought wink was sarcasm
james i need you to be completely honest
yeah did chappelle's wink scare you off
um it it unnerved
okay
it took me
it took me for a little bit of a roller
coaster right did you know my
experiences here pretty often
what's that did you know my intentions
of the wink
uh i get i guess i guess you're you are
just a ride or die you're gonna sell for
your advertisers but we do we do hear it
all the time that we uh
that it really is uh the
co-founder of twitch said it was his
favorite product discovery of the last
five years so you do hear that kind of
thing all the time and so when you said
that i was like oh no i know i genuinely
mean it
no he said when you he said when you
disconnected because we all yelled at
him for the wink he said that was to
tell james thank you for the good pride
that's like hey wink uh but the
co-founder oh
i was gonna
i'm segwaying i'm segwaying everybody
the co-founder of twitch is a guy named
justin khan who was one of the many
guests on james bashara's podcast that
he hosts below the line which if i do
say so myself is one of the best
produced podcasts i've ever ever seen
it rivals this one
wow
we were blurry two episodes ago but
let's not talk about it
uh he just said tell us about i take uh
i take full responsibility for that
compliment and i love it because it
takes
it takes a show creator to choose a
producer
it does to choose wisely and so whatever
happens under that umbrella i take i
take full credit for so thank you nick
that it that means a lot yeah no we we
work together for listeners we work
together that's how i know that the
cat's ad crew is through nick helping
produce um produces
immediately
i think the name below the line sounds
kind of similar in another podcast it
works on coincidence coincidence
i thought you were starting like a very
specific branding what i will say to do
a plug within a plug magic mind is also
a sponsor of
another below deck podcast
which is one of the best
if i don't see my soul myself hosted
podcasts
rivals this one and below the line
a lot of bibles there's a lot of rivals
a lot of rivals in the room and
and as as a small company that that
advertises on cats after dark i'll be
honest i can't keep track of where the
funds go because they go in and then
back out and there's a heavy movement of
money between advertising on cats after
dark working with nick on below the line
below deck then below the deck and cats
after dark advertisers the advertising
then sends money back into magic
and i'm cross-eyed
it is a wicked it is a wicked web we've
weaved
i will say i'm the only one keeping
track of it because i alerted your team
that i was paid twice for a below deck
sponsorship
i could have kept it in my pocket
honestly right there thank you uh but i
will say about below the line also
that's why we're and that's why we're
going to sign up for more episodes on
below deck and cat's out
that's amazing uh also on below the line
recently he just had a guy you may know
brian callan hour and a half
very oh just some guy who used to be on
mad tv
tv
it's sad i heard he's just using his
hair now
but uh yeah a different side of brian
than you may know from fighter and the
kid so and also pete holmes and then a
myriad of other guests that are
incredible yeah that was getting the
momentum that episode was really
really cool it was uh he he shared more
than i've ever heard him share on just
what below line is uh
um it is a cardinal sin i'm not talking
about a podcast on another podcast
i like it it's
well to
just the the to give some context of the
title below line is basically what
happens beneath the the water line of an
iceberg ninety percent of what's going
on for a creator
um just never gets talked about and they
don't give that like chabelle i love
when you talk about how
i remember you saying one time three
podcasts uh promoting constantly and
it's still just such a grind selling
tickets building an audience is not for
the faint of heart yeah and and it's
those brief moments that i love as a
creator i've been building startups for
15 years and i just love
those brief insights that you can get
into how hard
this [ __ ] is oh yeah people don't you
don't realize it like like it's a lot
of work like it's like you
you can't just do the minimal work for
anything i mean you never could to be to
begin with but like
to make something happen you have to go
almost above and beyond especially
nowadays because there's so many people
that are trying to do things and create
stuff i think you know you you have to
really find
your way in what works for you and what
gets you noticed the most you know
how many how many years have you been
have you been doing this doing what
existing
dirty stand up oh stand up stand up uh
it was like existing 35 uh
stand up
uh nine years
and then podcasting when i do cats
uh twenty
i joined right uh when the pandemic hit
yeah so it's 2020
2020 that was only two years ago yeah oh
wow what yeah that's what i'm only been
doing it for two years yeah i feel like
the real journey though to
to the point of how long it takes and
how much grind there is is the nine
years of stand up you didn't get on the
podcast and tell you it did seven years
of stand up yes yes well yeah that's and
that's the part that i love chatting
with with chabelle we'd love to have you
on the line because
oh wow look at that
[Laughter]
and and it it it really is uh that's my
favorite part of talking to creators
that's what the whole podcast is about
is is the the journey between the years
of just managing your psychology through
nine years anyone that i think from the
outside most people not everyone but
the vast majority look from the outside
and they're like oh yeah it's a grind
for 16 months and then you like catch a
wave for like 22 months
no that [ __ ] is a hundred straight
months
of thinking okay yeah on the corner
around the corner around the corner and
until maybe you get enough of a
perspective maybe two years in three
years in probably in my entrepreneurial
journey of building startups i probably
realized maybe
four years in i was like no this is like
any other craft this is going to take
taking 10 years four years
yeah and i just thought oh it's around
the corner it's around the corner for
four years before i was like all right
let me give this a healthy dose of
reality and it's going to take 10 years
and and yes it's been 15 of building
startups and yeah probably didn't catch
a wave till until right about 10 years
in and actually today specifically it's
been two years for one journey happy
birthday to magic mind
yes happy birthday magic
yeah that's that and that's such a
[ __ ] uh version of the story too
it's two years but it was like
nine seven years before that of
tinkering and iterating it was a year
before it launched of like just getting
the branding right making sure the
product
tastes good and it's you chop everyone
and we have to because no one wants very
few people unless you're creators or
interested in that kind of stuff want to
hear that whole story so you chop off
that part and then yes i don't know
chappelle's story is gonna be in two
years it's gonna be like oh i got on to
king the sting and even he will be
forced to shorten the story and
and we all i'm every single one of you
all has like a 10-year story
that i don't know you just at some point
in your career you just chop it off and
people don't hear that part
yeah that's amazing i love it deep i
love it
this episode is called below the line
of cats after darkness
could i ask you guys just i know that uh
uh you'll have much more interesting
things to chat about but for listeners
to hear
you all have touched on in previous
episodes but i'd love to hear everyone's
nine-year version the 10-year version
just like two minutes each like nick
you were living out of your car
i was working at a mixed martial art
company i was the only employee of this
guy who was
importing goods from india i got it down
well we've talked we've talked a decent
amount uh but uh
yeah i i quit
next chin so
i'm ready was like uh chin was in a gang
okay almost killed a guy
he's never in the gang he led the gang
he has the scars to prove it he does
uh quit my job
lived in my car drove cross country to
la seven months didn't get a job got an
internship for free for the adam carolla
show for three months uber it's 70 hours
a week while i was interning for free
for 30. uh met theo vaughn there
in between their work for funny or die
got laid off when they laid off a third
of their company uh and then hooked up
with theo and we took off boom
yeah i mean and
yeah i got chills
well seriously that i mean everyone
i got chills when you when he said that
and and you did in a cocktail
setting and a dinner setting that part
just
gets like
you just like let go of that part of the
story
that was so
critical and probably extremely
stressful emotional uncertain obviously
you didn't have this certainty that it
would work out and yet you let go of
that part of the story and and someone
says what do you do and you just like go
right into the here and now and people
don't get the insight into how hard
how
lucky it at times but also how risky um
you were able to you were willing to to
take
you know agency within your career chin
what's what is yours what's your below
the line version of how you're sitting
here today like a boss
like a boss yeah thanks dude no never
been in a gang
but uh just making sure everyone's jokes
inside jokes
i'm trying to like go through it so i
remember going to college i had no idea
what i wanted to do so i just kept
changing my major from art to music to
uh i think graphic or psychology and
then went to college for six years
transferred to different colleges
finally got to california state
university of long beach and then
i realized okay i was working also
full-time as a computer networking
engineer so i just made more money doing
that so i just went to school part-time
then just gave up on school i thought i
was just going to be a computer
networker then
went to
no change occupations from there because
i wanted to do music
record i went to school for music for
audio engineering
interned at a music studio
and then eventually moved over to
voiceover started recording voiceover
then what's your korean television
network
and then got laid off from that because
my my thing that i was doing as a
voiceover director for korean a korean
television show which was dubbed in
spanish so i would train spanish
voiceover when was that what what year
was that dang it was five six years ago
about six six yeah six years ago and
then when i got so my department cost
too much money so they laid off my art
department and uh we call it outsourced
to argentina so then i was like oh what
am i gonna do now
and i loved podcasting and i heard
brendan on joe rogan's show saying like
they're leaving fox they need a producer
so i started writing into their you know
their final kid shop because they had no
email there no there's like no contacts
and got no responses so i just made a
little usb drive i put all my my resume
all the music i did how i built the
studios all that stuff into a little usb
drive that looked like a lego and i
found that brandon was gonna be better
meatballs interested
and then i found out brenda's gonna be
at a
hollywood improv
so i went there with one of my buddies
saw him there when he walked off stage i
just went up to him like i just handed
my drive and i was like yeah i could be
your next producer just check out you
know check out the drive
and then i got the job this might be a
virus that empties all of your bank
accounts or resume
that's what i was like i don't know if i
want to stick this in my computer but
all right
we'll give it a shot yeah
yeah he probably borrowed brian's hey
brian can i follow you i don't know
you know brenda never uses computers
brendan has never owned a laptop or a
computer
i believe how crazy is that so his
brother took the uh that is
it's insane
but that's a younger generation too i
think now yeah yeah i'm on an ipad i i
never use a laptop either there you go
ipad pro
oh those are 2018 ipad pro for
everything but okay cat what about see
okay so that is a perfect example chin
that it's like
that's what a career looks like it looks
like you're wandering and it looks like
there's like these stutters oh yeah big
time a break oh i'm catching a break
nick same thing
i bet chappelle i bet you could
you could recount a few times or you're
like [ __ ] yeah i just caught a break
this is it yeah yeah and then
it's like the real break seems to come
when you're so faded
you're so jaded from catching a break
that it can you stop catching you stop
i don't keeping count
if that's how many times you you have to
seemingly catch a break before it really
is a break and you actually kind of uh
you actually get taken in by some wave
of something bigger than yourself but uh
i remember in building startups first
two companies complete failures and i
was just like
oh we got this investor oh man we got
this number of of customers oh wow this
press and i just thought oh this is
going to break wide open and then
it's you you stop keeping you stop
putting any expectations on on something
outside of just like the process
just doing it over and over and over
again but that's brilliant perseverance
uh going above and beyond to get your
your resume in front of brandon brendan
what about you kat
well i actually went to college to study
theater because i did terribly in high
school and really wanted to leave san
jose i have tiger parents they would not
let me
go or do anywhere unless they were
absolutely sure that i could make a
living
and i was like how can i get out of san
jose as fast as possible i'm going to
try to audition to every art school i
can and i happen to get into usc which
got me out of san jose and on my senior
year there after having
terrible terrible time there because i
just did not know how to
adapt in a university setting i was on
academic probation for a good year and a
half almost flunked out of college
uh senior year i started to actively try
my best and
i did really well and i really didn't
know what i wanted to do after
graduation because what are you gonna do
with a [ __ ] theater degree in la like
that might as well throw that out the
door um i ended up dming brendan during
the last quarter of my senior year and
he said oh i actually do need an intern
but i need one right now can you start
working and i couldn't because my
theater department had me doing classes
from
10 a.m to 11 p.m so i was at school
every day from 10 to 11 could not do it
once i graduated i dm'd him again like
hey offer still stands like i will come
work for you for free i just i need the
i really want the experience
so i came i interned and i had a small
salary off the top which helped a lot
but then i needed to find other jobs to
supplement living in la as expensive of
a city it was i
took on two extra jobs which then became
three jobs so i was working for jobs at
one time
because i really wanted to stay on the
podcast and so i was doing all these
extra odd jobs in order to keep that one
and i would work my schedule around
recording these podcasts i would work
right after right before
that one to two hour slot and once i
said that make sense to your parents no
absolutely not and my parents are like
refugee immigrants my dad works two
three jobs all the time and you told me
you need to calm down this is too much
you're doing the most like just come
home or find something else it's fine
but i was so determined to make it work
that i kept doing it until i absolutely
couldn't i had a conversation with
brendan and he's like wait why are you
doing all this just work for me full
time like why are you working for jobs i
was like i don't know
i didn't wanna like i don't know it just
never occurred to me to ask for a
full-time position and when i did he
took me on right under his wing and
that's how i got here that's
that is a lesson i have also had to
learn over and over and over again of um
it never hurts to ask and yet
and your your
story sums up you dm'd for the
internship it already worked to put
yourself out there and ask and yet you
forget the story you forget the the
results of that four or five months
later and you stop asking or you stop
persevering for
advocating for what you want but that's
uh
yeah it never for any listeners
especially in entrepreneurship
shamelessly ask ask ask ruthless i'm i
still
fire off
four or five emails a day that i just
know four are never gonna get a reply
and one might and you just get like so
numb to
to being ignored and it's and it's
awesome because one out of five you know
this thing that you like just lobbed a
request over it works
and so you just keep doing it but at
this point yeah completely numb to just
asking asking asking
and yet i'll still find myself in a
situation where i forget um like to
actually like push at a dinner where i'm
next to the founder of air one or
something it's like oh i should push to
get magic mine into air one and and i'll
after the dinner be like why didn't i do
that and and just have to relearn the
lesson what has it been like um
like even right now does it make sense
to your parents and what is that
feel like central tension in a lot of
creators lives is what you want for
yourself and what others want of you
yeah uh it absolutely makes sense now
speaking of like that asking and getting
no replies that's so funny because i
actually did email i remember emailing
fighter and the kid i emailed theo i
emailed tiger belly before like i
i emailed so many different podcasts
that i was listening to and the only
response i got was from brendan
and so that like you just gotta keep
asking even if you get no response
but now it makes a lot of sense to my
parents i think a big part of that is
they just wanted to make sure that i was
gonna be okay that i could stand on my
own two feet but the first paycheck
i got and granted this isn't my podcast
paycheck like once i hit only fans and i
started making like big girl money i
paid off my parents house so to them
they're like oh this makes sense that
was the first thing i did with the money
and they were like oh yeah like do
whatever you want yeah that'll quiet
some criticisms quick
no but my parents were so supporting for
like immigrant parents who wanted kids
to come to this country and be like
lawyers or doctors and i told them i
wanted to play pretend on tv because i
wanted to be like a wwe star when i was
eight uh for them to like let me just go
and pursue one i what i wanted to do it
was
like
as much as it was
for them to pay off their house it was
more so like
i want to do this for like it's almost
like for me to be able to give it to
them like i'm doing a good thing for you
but it's kind of for me to just show
like i can't do it
well these these kinds of stories i
think are so
empowering for
for
people that listen
and and feel like their story is
different
like especially in the startup game
where people are like [ __ ]
like
instagram was like from one idea to a
billion dollars 13 months later oh this
isn't happening like that it's like no
that's one that's not even the real
story like the instagram messed up so
bad with their first version the first
year that they rebranded completely and
started over
but i remember thinking oh that's the
story that i should be shooting for not
only was it incorrect but two you'd hear
the the real stories of people and and
you realize oh they were 17 months in
feeling like they had gone 10 steps
backward instead of feeling like they
had made any progress
or or it's securing your story that you
just kept where it's
you go through this spell
where people around you just don't
understand jeff bezos has this uh great
quote of um
innovators must have the willingness to
be misunderstood
and once you hear it and like kind of
clicks of like
oh i'm not understood by any of my
friends or family members why i'm doing
this xyz whatever you're going after and
then you hear that that sound bite of
top three richest people in the world
saying you've got to have a willingness
to be a misunderstood you're like oh
that's a superpower that i'm able to do
this and yeah it might be three years it
might be nine years before it makes
sense to them but this is exactly how it
should feel is misunderstood and my
willingness to be on a limb and do
something that doesn't make sense to my
friends or family or parents absolutely
i i love that i that bezos quote about
i've i've i've said to myself like no
one understands your vision until it
comes to fruition like you can tell
someone exactly a plan you have i'm like
i know this is gonna work and like
there's just like blank stairs and i'm
like
but
you so you can't let it you can't let it
deter you because
they'll be like oh right that's what you
meant yeah
no it's it your vision is a doorway that
really only
fits you
it you can't and you waste too much time
trying to get
15 friends from back home your your
parent it just it will not fit
then it is just
made for you and um but when you go
through it and you go through it a
couple times
then you're on this other side and like
you said then it makes sense then and
honestly you get past even caring about
bringing them along
they're jumping through the door with it
now they see an exists and you're on to
the next and the next and the next you
just get so comfortable like riding a
bike
so comfortable
doing something on a tuesday or thursday
a friday night at 9 00 pm while your
friends are doing something else and not
being understood and you're just so
comfortable with it you're like yeah
this is this is actually where i'm most
at home you know what would be an
incredible tease
instead of hearing and we'll make we can
hear christians too uh
instead of hearing chappelle's right now
we get him in studio for below the line
uh
hell yeah
hey we do we do it that's how you hear
chappelle's bull below the line which
would be like 90 minutes in a week or
two on below the line
[Applause]
yeah i was in san francisco for 10 years
and we just moved down two years ago
well that was aggressive huh that was
very aggressive
meatball how did you get here
uh
how i get here uh no one cares i'm just
kidding
man do this [ __ ] yourself
um nothing i i was just like working in
rhode island and just trying to figure
out where i wanted to go to college and
i knew i didn't want to stay in rhode
island
both my brothers were in la at the time
so i decided to go to community college
out here just to give it a shot i ended
up mark majoring in marketing and
advertising uh
during that i was working as a busser
host like at a bunch of different
restaurants i was so broke i was even
doing wags walking people's dogs for
about twelve dollars an hour um probably
one of the worst experiences of my life
uh cut to a year later i'm still working
at better restaurant i'm working at a
restaurant sleeping on a
couch with my friends spending all my
money just friends
another grown man yeah another grown man
i was paying 80s
opposite of rent where you're getting
paid a couple favors
but yeah so we were crammed into a couch
so like i struggled there for
until i graduated santa monica college
uh i was in the process of
doing work with miller light for because
i was selling them a commercial and then
kovit hit shut all of it down i moved
home worked at a gun store for a year
and uh my older brother who has been has
known nick for about five years nick and
theo uh was reached out to by brennan
saying that they needed a new social
media guy so my brother recommended me
uh brendan texted me that day and a week
later i had already i packed up all my
[ __ ] and came back out here to start
here
well it's
uh that's a pr another perfect example
of one extreme dedication perseverance
and still like the stutter starts
and
you think it's all happening and then
something like copic completely out of
uh our control happens in our in our
journeys and then you go back home
did you go back home and think i'm never
going back or did you for at least to
spell or did you go back home even on
your way there you're like oh i'm going
back i knew i i was going back so i was
collect i was uh here for about three
months in the beginning of the pandemic
but i didn't like just sitting at home
collecting unemployment i want i like
like to work for my money so i was just
applying applying applying for jobs uh
all the time and then i was only
supposed to go to rhode island for a
week but when i was home i got offered a
job at my friend's gun store so i was
like okay yeah i don't have anything in
la so i'll work here until i figure out
a plan uh and find a job back in la so
it was only uh temporary and then i got
the job here and then that's why i came
back out
so i knew i knew deep down i was a 50
million dollar home and pacific house
pretty soon
that magic mind money
[Laughter]
so look out for this episode of below
the line this is gonna be a huge influx
of numbies
uh the server's ready man
uh but james thank you so much yeah
thank you thank you thank you for a year
and we have it we have it recorded on
video thank you for your continued
support for magic mind yes cats after
dark
thank you for i love it
it is it's really fun to support what
y'all are doing uh i mean it's just a
great show to begin with but it's also
um you guys are all so lovable and and
it's fun to be in this
this um tiny little universe uh and
who knows who's gonna end up with
with um
with the most money with all this
movement of funds but you know that's
why i'm rubbing elbows with nick every
day yeah he might be the kingpin in a
few years and we might uh all be working
for him
i'll tell you one thing cat is in the
lead
yeah she is
she's in the lane right now
cold out yeah
i agree with you though in a few years
nick might be like the suge knight of
podcasting
that's the vibe i get exactly especially
i'll run any one of you
all right guys well i appreciate it yeah
it's a company of three people so we're
a small small little outfit but it is it
is a lot of fun to listen to the ad
reads from you all every week
[Laughter]
all of the support
james is gonna hop off this and onto a
zoom with like carl icahn or something
[Laughter]
no i'm actually you know what i'm
actually gonna go play with my
four-year-old
she is waiting waiting patiently and
then
well thank you so much for your time and
tell her thank you for her time because
we did yeah okay
i can see her thank you guys and she's
just moving
yeah
and chappelle uh she i'm actually mr
president not questions but she rappell
i'm gonna hit you up and we'll get you
on below the line you don't want to find
me man i'm on this [ __ ]
there's a child in the room child of the
room
all right
oh that was awesome he like uh we're
like i love the segment odd cats after
dark up below the line like that yeah i
was i was fascinated by all you guys
sam i think i forget how
much goes on before all of us got here
and so kind of hearing individually what
each of us were doing
i totally forgot that chin used to work
at a different network like a nail salon
what sorry what that was racist
out of korea you got to make money dude
you got to make money somehow that's
true yeah
i loved that
so it was a korean television show that
was dubbing over to spanish that got
outsourced oh because they speak spanish
in argentina i was like they get a third
language
okay
either way still convoluted yeah what a
crazy yeah crazy gig that's what i was
like like what happened in what order
i'm like trying to figure out
so it's trippy when you ask that i'm
like oh crap mine's a lot
yeah so that's why you need nine minutes
that's actually actually smart that you
did that i was like mine's kind of crazy
i didn't do that to cut you off i'd
below the line
below the line
below the line
all right where's the sixth grader at
yeah next week that's next week oh yeah
yeah yeah uh what uh
i we have i want him to go on sporkle
press random when we play one thing
game of sparkle yeah scorcle.com
uh because it's only it's 320.
yes yes it is
39. i just oh 339
all right wrap it i got it i want i oh
yeah yeah cause you gotta
i mean no he's he has to clean up a
possum and take it to the to the animal
shelter my friend's out of town and uh
his girl has like an autoimmune disease
and she can't leave the house and
there's this she's like a huge animal
lover they look i'm not kidding 32 cats
in their house that's true i'm not
kidding it's insane um
and there's like a possum that like died
or it's like hurt in the backyard that
they need help bringing to the animal
hospital i wish i didn't live so close
because they know where i lived like can
you come help us i'm like
yeah
my favorite part of that is he said it's
either hurt or died
i love that as we're talking about this
this lot this possum's life is like
yeah we're just sitting here he's in
here
it could be dead it could be dead
or struggling he's saying it's hurt or
dead or it's playing possum i don't know
yeah
when my grandmother would wake me up in
the morning for school she was like oh
you're playing possum
well i'll let you guys know if he's
playing possum or he's really awesome
look at it
exactly they just go
it's kind of cute though
i don't
[Laughter]
this is on the other part on other
podcast network isn't it
ears looked weird to me
this is a regular steve irwin
i googled it quickly
never seen a
you ever seen possum
possum lady
oh my dad's never seen a skunk until he
came to the u.s he tried to capture it
and sprayed him
yep he's like 20. they do do that he's
doing here that's a big ass possum
they're all that big might be ingesting
since we were talking about origin
stories and people trying to make [ __ ]
happen why don't y'all make [ __ ] happen
and come see me perform may 6th and 7th
in [ __ ] san diego
i just cussed my whole promo for san
diego it was aggressive but hey
show up you know what i mean i'll be at
mike drop comedy club it's new comedy
club
uh i'm doing the opening weekend the
grand opening weekend of that club so
that would be fun and plus uh i've never
headlined san diego so it'd be nice if
you san diego ends come on out uh also
i'll be doing a one-nighter in my
hometown in phoenix and stand up live
may 12th and then
meatball uh is gonna come hang out with
me at comedy connection in rhode island
i know there's gonna be a line of people
in rhode island wanting to meet them uh
which would be amazing you know what i
mean meatball meet and greet yeah
meatball meet and greet you go hey help
me sell my merch okay yeah he's got me
and uh yeah that's it for me
oh yeah uh i'm not doing anything
like anywhere so that's cool catch me um
at home or on only fans
slash
cat i don't type it in you do this every
week no i was gonna that was gonna be
the same
and it's not i it's not like him being
like mean or anything it's just like i
get so embarrassed i try to tell you i
he's trying to be like a good friend and
like support me but i'm like meanwhile
stop no you and i did talk about it and
as i was typing and she's like i
shouldn't be doing this but i was like
it was just that you like looked at me
he was just a habit
[Laughter]
i
went to facebook so much i was just
typing i'm like i'm not even trying to
go on my computer right now why am i
typing in facebook that's that's why i'm
kind of glad she stopped me because i
didn't want it to i didn't want it to
show it's a memory love it gin
um
same old stuff catch this vlog about his
time is great
birthday oh no yeah my birthday was my
birthday but also the thick boy album i
think the drop date is april 29th i just
asked him before the episode so i could
plug it and then i forgot so i'm glad
you did i think it's the 29th i'm not
100 sure so the day after brendan's
special yes or the day release day is
april 28th april 28th
that's a special release though that's
that's a saturday
maybe it's like in conjunction with hmm
or something junction what's your
function um
yeah and he has one song released on his
uh on the thick boy youtube standing o
with mike stud yeah and there's like
jelly rolls gonna be on the album mike
stud is gonna be on album look at little
bras obviously me
and a bunch of other chapelle chapelle
my band's got shows coming yeah i'll
announce those whenever i want that's
exciting are you on the album yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah mark harley's on
there
a little bit you know
vocals [ __ ] vocals bars bars catch me
ball on instagram i see paulo
six
if it is a band if it is a band 50 50
shot yeah 5050 shot nick
the ultimatum on netflix if anybody's
watching we're covering that on my
patreon patreon.com another podcast
network and on that patreon we have love
is blind seasons one and two covered
flavor of love
there you go that's a great one
i mean best
me and my two friends we can recap
reality any reality show and make it
really funny even if i hate the show
yeah ultimatum's okay though oh i know
you guys have talked about a fighter in
the kid
yeah
it smells like we did
i remember there was there's like a dell
he sounded mean she does
or she looks like handsome squidward
that's a great reference that's a great
reference also because you have a long
face doesn't mean you're ugly it doesn't
this is long just more i've got a lot of
beautiful
bars in every single way if you want to
catch that voice words can't bring me
down
and
this must have been just one of our
listeners that made that side by side
because it's not coming up but she looks
exactly like him i've called the girl
before i heard her him call brendan call
her long face i called her uh handsome
she's a very handsome woman yeah there
are some people who are hanging
somebody's sitting here dissing this
girl
nice girl yeah i'm saying she's handsome
oh got it okay okay okay he says she's
handsome i think it's a compliment but
it has a certain connotation yes certain
kind
all right uh
we i say we end it with the nick sent me
the cats after dark scenes uh theme song
that someone sent in so i say we end it
with that good job there you go thank
you i forgot a good one
[Music]
i love that intro
this is like a month and a half late
better late than never
he said in his email episode 3 was super
funny
11
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just looks
i'm actually going to denver
[Music]
win
jewels
we own and we did it all on our own
everybody left cali but we made
calabasas our home our own two we stood
on y'all flip flop y'all two-toned we
too grown to be told can't cancel us joe
rogan good luck coming for the crown boy
you know sitting on this
blonde studio
[Music]
[Music]
come on
well maybe not the world but definitely
the best podcast on sundays
see no longer
[Laughter]
shout out to booty pirates see ya bye
[Music]
[Music]
you